Rockets are incredibly powerful you can
launch yourself into orbit fly the moon
and soon enough travel to Mars but to go
beyond our solar system yeah you're
gonna need something else
solar sails
how exactly would sales work out in
space
how long would it take you to travel to
the edge of the solar system
and why could this journey end with your
slow and lonely demise
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you sailed the Galaxy on solar
winds
to launch a spaceship you need a rocket
to push you up into the sky
that push is called thrust
being launched from Earth with the power
of a rocket gives a spacecraft most of
its momentum after this you'd need more
fuel to change your speed or course
but there are no gas stations out there
in space for you to refuel and that
means you can only go as far as your
fuel takes you
see more fuel means more weight and in
space your reserves are limited
in other words it would be really hard
to get to your Interstellar destination
with rockets alone
but all of that is about to change
All Aboard you're set to sail across the
Galaxy
you know if anything breaks down in the
debt of space it'll be on you to fix it
but back on Earth we don't always have
that ability not by choice but because
some of the biggest manufacturers around
don't want us to have access to fix
their products this practice allows
companies to keep a lock on the market
and limit your choices as a consumer
that's a backdoor way for them to create
a monopoly this Stranglehold on the
market puts the smaller more affordable
repair shops out of business because
they can't compete without the tools
needed to do their jobs
currently over two dozen state
legislatures are crafting laws to defend
your right to repair making these
business practices illegal look to their
credit Apple has reversed some of its
policies but they still maintain a huge
amount of proprietary control and some
other companies don't take this issue
seriously so urge your lawmakers to
fight for your rights as a consumer and
Take Back Control of what belongs to you
after all you paid for it
now let's get back to the video
on Earth sales have been moving boats
around the globe for centuries they work
without any fuel only the power of wind
but out in space there are no air
particles moving around so you'd need to
harness a different kind of wind
solar winds carry charged particles
ejected by the Sun
these particles fly across the solar
system at a blisteringly fast 1.6
million kilometers per hour
but with a special type of sale you
could take advantage of that power to
get yourself across the solar system and
beyond
and no those special sales wouldn't look
much like the sales you're familiar with
are you ready to have your mind blown
this is the contraption that could take
you across the Galaxy it's called
electric sales or e-sales they're kind
of like an umbrella without fabric only
these ribs would be made of electrically
charged aluminum wires and they can be
as long as 20 kilometers while also
being no thicker than about half of one
strand of hair upon your head now all
you'd need is the solar wind and you
could sail across the deep dark sea of
outer space
wait wait wait wait
um there's one catch you see you'd still
need chemical Rockets to launch you off
into space to begin with
that's because electric sales don't work
within Earth's magnetosphere
the magnetosphere is the area around the
planet that's under the influence of its
magnetic field
it's up to 10 times larger than Earth
itself and to escape it you'd need a
little boost from the old school Rockets
or you could build a Spaceport around
Earth
it would have to be far enough so that
the planet's magnetic field doesn't
reach it
but you know that would get too
expensive and take too long to construct
and we want to send you on this journey
right now
so you'd launch your ship from Earth and
out of the magnetosphere's limits
from there it would be smooth sailing
with a 1 000 kilogram spacecraft like
yours you'd have about 100 wires to
catch solar wind particles
you'd be a Pioneer voyaging through
space with this fantastic new technology
after one year of sailing you'd reach a
speed of at least 30 kilometers per
second
and you might even go as fast as 150
kilometers per second yeah and that's
really fast faster than Voyager 1 the
fastest space probe humans have ever
sent off world
the Voyager 1 probe is hurtling through
space at about 17 kilometers per second
after spending three years getting past
Mars Jupiter Saturn and Uranus you'd end
up beyond the orbit of Neptune you'd
navigate by simply changing the voltage
levels on different wires of your
electric sails yeah well you'd still
have to be a navigational genius to sail
safely
especially when you get closer to the
outer edges of the solar system
here you have to pass through the Kuiper
belt
this area is filled with icy comets and
if you're not careful these comets will
do some Hefty damage to your electric
sails
yeah your Interstellar trip might end
before you even get out of our planetary
neighborhood
after that you've still got a long way
to go to the very end of the solar
system the heliopause
it's four times further away from the
Sun than Neptune
so fasten your seat belts and power
through a pretty uneventful view for
about 10 more years
I know I know you'd prefer a view of
Jupiter or a Uranus instead but hey it's
almost time to explore worlds you've
never seen
I just remembered I was supposed to tell
you something important
yeah you know how your electric sails
need solar winds to sale
well uh now you'd be the furthest from
the Sun you've ever been and that means
there won't be as many solar particles
pushing your spaceship forward
your sailing might just come to a
complete stop leaving you stuck forever
in the outskirts of the solar system
cold lonely and hopeless
yeah I'm not gonna lie this could be how
your days come to an end
so while you still have some life left
in your sales you'll need to navigate to
another star
if I were you I'd head to the Alpha
Centauri star system
it's the closest one around and it has
not one but three stars
now you should also know that not all
stars are equal in providing you the
powerful solar winds you so desperately
need passing by a red dwarf star like
Alpha Centauri C also known as Proxima
Centauri you'd experience luminosities
that could be anywhere from one tenth to
one ten thousandth as strong as our own
Sun
but despite this you might be able to
gain enough accelerating power to reach
super high speeds once again
and all this without any chemical fuel
yeah going green is the cool new thing
everyone's talking about
okay now that you've made it further
into space than any human has ever dared
to go
well you should probably explore what
else is out there like some of the
planets scientists have discovered that
might be even better for life than Earth
but that's a story
for another
what if